es war eine geste der solidarität als
ich kurz vor der sitzung des un
sicherheitsrates die botschafter der
europäischen union hinter ihrem
ukrainischen kollegen und seiner fahne
versammelten schon da war klar dass es
eine außergewöhnliche sitzung werden
würde die usa in albanien hatten eine
resolution zur abstimmung eingebracht
die den russischen angriffskrieg in der
ukraine verurteilt aber es ging um sehr
viel mehr
ich sage es ganz offen stimmt mit ja
juni die charta der vereinten nationen
aufrechterhalten wollen wenn ihr die
souveränität und die territoriale
integrität der ukraine und die jeden
anderen staates unterstützt wenn ihr
überzeugt seid dass russlands präsent
handeln zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
muss stimmt mit nein oder enthalten euch
wenn ihr nicht hinter der charta der
vereinten nationen steht und euch gemein
macht mit dem aggressiven und
provozierten handeln russlands
russland das war klar würde die
resolution mit einem veto belegen
russlands botschafter bezichtigte den
westen der lüge und der propaganda
russische truppen bombardieren keine
ukrainischen städte wir haben gesagt
dass sie nicht bedroht sind es gibt
keine verifizierbare bestätigung über
den tod von zivilisten
die frage war wer wird russland
unterstützen und gegen die resolution
stimmen oder sich enthalten immer wieder
wurde die sitzung verschoben wollten die
usa und andere china und indien
überzeugen der resolution zuzustimmen
ohne erfolg indien die vereinigten
arabischen emirate und china enthielten
sich der stimme
die legitimen sicherheitsbedenken aller
staaten müssen berücksichtigt werden
vor dem hintergrund von fünf
erweiterungsrunden der nato richtung
osten muss man verstehen dass russlands
sicherheitsbedenken berücksichtigt
werden müssen
wir bedanken uns bei denen die diese
resolution nicht unterstützt haben elf
ja stimmen 3 enthaltungen und einer
gegenstimme für die vereinten nationen
und die weltordnung diese repräsentieren
eine zäsur denn das ergebnis macht eines
klar ein völkerrechtswidriger
angriffskrieg wird im sicherheitsrat
nicht mehr von allen staaten abgelehnt
am ende der sitzung bat die ukraine um
eine gedenk minute für die opfer des
krieges unterbrochen vom russischen
botschafter und mit applaus bedacht von
der mehrheit der anwesenden vertreter
nach dieser denkwürdigen sitzung haben
wir mit johannes hahn droht morgen
gesprochen und natürlich über die
kernfrage wie man dieses ergebnis oder
das votum werden kann
[Musik]
sind die mitglieder des sicherheitsrates
die auf deren aufgabe es ist diese den
weltfrieden herzustellen stehen die noch
hinter der charta der vereinten nationen
oder nicht und insofern war das
abstimmungsergebnis dann doch sehr
interessantes länder haben für diese
resolution gestimmt aber eben auch drei
haben sich enthalten china indien die
beiden atommächte und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate dass russland nein
sagt war klar aber es hat heute ziemlich
klar ist ziemlich klar geworden muss man
sagen dass es eben wichtige länder in
dieser welt gibt die einen angriffskrieg
nicht mehr ablehnen als mittel der
politik das muss man so sagen bleiben